it was billed as perhaps the uk's worst
storm in 30 years with winds expected of
140 kilometers an hour but that's a mere
breeze compared to what storm eunice
actually delivered a gust on the isle of
wight topped 190 kilometers an hour and
has provisionally become the uk's
strongest recorded wind for all eunice's
fury though the damage could have been a
whole lot worse
if as i say the surge had coincided with
the winds and the high tide we could
have seen some devastation hence the
severe flood warnings and some
evacuations so i'm really happy that
those things have gone out of sync but
it was great that everyone was prepared
and the public listed and people kept
themselves safe eunice has killed and
injured people though fatalities from
falling trees have been confirmed in the
uk ireland and the netherlands but in
most places the damage has been to
property rather than lives
now this rather sorry site here is
london's o2 arena formerly known as the
millennium dome it's a huge great
concert and exhibition space in london
south east featured in james bond films
and the like but as you can see storm
eunice has shredded a huge great hole in
its fabric skin really ripped it apart
it's going to be some effort to fix that
one i think
and then there was the disruption
travelers anxiously watched information
boards as train after train was
cancelled
there was gridlock on many roads this
tailback was caused by the closure of
the dartfor bridge part of london's m25
orbital motorway
400 plus flights were grounded too
now every disaster needs a hero and
cometh the hour cometh big jet tv the
aviation enthusiasts live web stream
isn't used to large audiences but more
than 200 000 logged on as host jerry
dyer's live commentary went viral
cheering on planes as they struggle to
land at heathrow easy
easy easy easy
go on son
oh okay tippy toe
is it too cold
yeah
big swing man
eunice has moved fast sweeping across
the uk and ireland in less than a day
now the rest of northern europe is
taking its turn rory challenge al
jazeera london